heute wurden in der wiener rossauer
kaserne 15 soldaten des jagdkommandos in
die eu mittelmeer mission zu vier
verabschiedet sie werden die
einsatzkräfte an bord des deutschen
versorgungsschiffes mehr ab dem zweiten
märz 2014
bei der kontrolle und übernahme von
schiffen unterstützen
mit der mission so 4 geht die
europäische union gegen das organisierte
handeln und schulen von menschen im
mittelmeer vor
insgesamt nehmen 1900 soldatinnen und
soldaten mit fünf schiffen drei
hubschraubern sowie drei flugzeugen
daran teil
österreichische soldaten werden
zukünftig informationen über
flüchtlingsbewegungen sammeln sowie die
untersuchung von verdächtigen schiffen
vornehmen